[Applaudissements]
c'est un cadeau pour qui ces fonds plus
c'est pour moi voyez c'est pour toi peut
l'ouvrir
on a presque la même taille en faire en
fait tu as d'étalon or mais je suis mais
voilà je sais que vous partez au ski oui
on part demain par partie demain tous os
qui donc va être pas mal
ouais alors voila moi j'aime bien le ski
aussi parce que ben oui j'en ai fait il
ya longtemps j'en fais plus mal reçus
qu'ils aient plein je me rappelle dont
les wydadis qui est remarquablement bien
y avait donc vu juste voilà j'ai pensé
que la tenue que je portais dans le film
devrait pouvoir aller pour lui mais
parce que vous avez monsieur je peux pas
avec la taille c'est pas la tenue du
film parce qu'elle a été terriblement
portée et usé mais c'est la veille la
même nom a demandé ce qu'elle va aller
où
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas comment vous dire non mais
manquait le circuit quelque chose de lui
donner ça parce que c'est il avait passé
un truc alémany tient manager vous le
papier mais non est génial
[Applaudissements]
la commune est extrêmement seyante
elle met en valeur les hyper beau gosse
pourquoi j'ai perdu beaucoup non j'étais
hyper beau gosse à tout va très bien on
ira pas aussi d'un on été créée jeune
premier stage et que j'ai envers une
photo je vous regarde et vous allez bien
fait rare aux rivages revenir avec des
trucs quand vous ne vous fait pas mal ne
vous arrêtez pas éviter de pisser sur
les serrures